It wasn't about the fashion.
It was about the women.
That's what a super model is.
It's the first time
we're all together
in our fifties.
You see our photos.
So you feel that you know us.
When you come together
with your choosen family
I think that's emotional.
There is something about
that shared history that
we have.
I feel blessed that
we're here today.
We've all gone through
some many
things in our own lives.
Cindy,
Linda,
Christy and
Naomi
are still redefining what
it means to be a model.
There was a feeling
about them
that they
wanted more.
I was not seen as
a person who had
a voice in her own destiny.
He said you should lose
five pounds.
I got scared I didn't
belong.
But Linda's a chameleon.
She could really
become whatever
the photographer wanted
her to become.
I would do all these
great shows,
wear all these
beautiful dresses
but then when it come
time for the advertising
and I would not
be included.
I was gonna be bullied
for the color of my skin.
What I loved about
the girls,
they were a group
and that was so fabulous.
We were always together
and we made great
photos together.
You know I just felt like
to be together as a group,
it just was so fun.
They're my sisters.
We get this phone call
that George Michael wants to
shoot us in his video.
We made a decision.
I will do it.
I'm going to do it.
Yes, okay, I'll do it.
♫ Freedom ♫
Everything changed.
You can start to call
the shots
and be an active participant
in your career.
All of a sudden,
we were the physical
representations
of power.
I wanted to go further,
I wanted to push the envelope.
They brought their
artistry to the image.
They would see things
we didn't necessarily see.
They're like the Mona Lisa.
The face of her era.
They're larger than life.
♫ Freedom ♫
We helped break
down barriers.
I have to think of something
greather than myself.
When I first was referred to
as a supermodel,
I was like why are they
calling us this.
It wasn't about the hair
and the make-up.
It wasn't about the fashion.
It was about the women.
♫
That's what a supermodel is.